This would be easier with
a serrated knife I think.
A what knife?
(laughter)
(playful music)
Personally I love turkey.
I only eat poultry,
so I only chicken and turkey.
I think drumstick is definitely
my favorite part of the
turkey and there's only two,
so that's like it's a
very competitive thing.
I have zero cooking ability
and zero cooking experience.
I probably learned how to
boil water at a very old age.
That's sort of embarrassing to admit.
I just learned how to cut
an onion the other day.
When I was a freshman in
college, so when I was like 18.
I would say I'm the person that
kind of just shows up on Thanksgiving.
I have never carved a
turkey in my entire life.
(intense music)
(turkey gobbles)
Uh oh, I knew it. I knew it.
It's a trap.
It's always a trap.
Damn it.
(intense music)
I don't know.
Do we get a knife?
(energetic music)
Okay, so wait, what's our
game plan here? Middle?
So have you ever carved a turkey before?
No.
So this is your first time?
Yes.
And I'm a part of it?
Gotta angle it. This is really awkward.
Wait, I think it would work
with left-handed actually.
You're doing a great job.
Thanks. You're doing a
great job too, of eating.
But the leg gets in the way.
Do you cut the leg out
of the way first maybe?
Oh yeah! Cut the legs out.
I think you have a little
bit of turkey in your hair.
Oh my God, I do?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Oh my gosh, why is it
tied? There's string.
Do people usually do this?
S and M bondage.
(nervous laughter)
Should we have cut it over?
No, I don't think that's a thing.
(shouts)
It's like Disneyland.
Yeah.
Should we turn the plate around,
so you can do the other side?
I think you should do the other side.
I don't think anyone will show up
to our Thanksgiving party.
I'd feel better.
Yes please!
That'd be great. I'd
feel like he'd be like,
"you guys did a great
job". Cause look, we did.
We did.
(folksy music)
Cut down to the thigh. Have the legs
be pushed down by the wings.
That looks very different
from when we were doing it.
(folksy music)
The thigh bone, since it's cooked well,
should come off really
easily. It's nice and tender.
(folksy music)
So you're gonna cut off the
turkey breast, right here.
So we've got one breast there,
Oh that's nice.
and then cut down here.
Yeah, we didn't do that.
(folksy music)
You can see that it just
comes open at the joint there,
and you can tear it or
you can find the joint
and then you can just kinda cut it.
(folksy music)
What you wanna do is
you actually wanna cut
against the grain. So if you see here.
Now you've got your
beautifully carved turkey.
That looks--
It's pretty.
- [Both] Yeah.
Now we're gonna go with the drumstick.
What you wanna do is
you wanna find the joint
and then all you have to do is tear it.
Then, what you wanna do with the thigh,
you can just kinda take it out,
and now you can flip it
over and cut the thigh meat.
So, there you go.
See, you make this look so easy.
Okay, I thought we did a pretty good job,
but it is become apparent
to me that we did not.
I mean, I feel like, yeah we didn't.
(playful music)
This turkey carving experience,
I definitely feel like
I can brag to my family
now that I know how to carve a turkey.
I definitely didn't think there was
as much to it as there is.
Our only strategy going
into the carving process was
make it edible.
I mean, regardless of how
it's carved, I'm gonna eat it.
I do definitely have a
greater appreciation for
turkey carvers. It is art.
Every single turkey that I've seen carved,
even though I wasn't really
paying full attention,
didn't seem to look anything
like how Vaughn just showed us.
I don't think this has
inspired me to cook.
I think if anything it has deterred me.
I think I'll just stick to the microwave.
(playful music)
Anything with green, like sage,
would be really good here, or rosemary.
We've got--
Cilantro?
This is parsley.